the primary funding source of the david
pakman show is your support through our
membership program i invite you to sign
up at joinpakman.com grab yourselves a
membership we do an extra show every
single day for our paid members it's
called the bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad well thank you alex many people
enjoy the bonus show daily and so i
would not listen to alex jones on that
you can sign up at joinpacman.com and
use the coupon code big voting 22 big
voting 22 to get yourself a healthy
discount off of the cost of a membership
there is a video going viral of
pro-choice activists crushing
yes the democratic party
over immediate opportunistic fundraising
attempts saying oh the supreme court
overturned roe v wade rush us money give
us money so that we can fix this and
we're going to look at that video now i
am
thrilled that this is getting attention
in fact
i tweeted about the vile nature of both
sides immediately fundraising off of the
supreme court decision last week i
tweeted quote is there anyone not
raising money off of today's supreme
court decision fundraising emails off
the charts right-wingers saying now is
the time to keep going give us money
left-wingers saying give us money to fix
this and i didn't find either of those
uh
particularly good faith uh rather
finding it completely opportunistic so
let's check out this video which has
gone completely viral this this is zoe
warren and julianne dioretta of rise up
for abortion they spoke to msnbc
and they beautifully point out the
absurdity now
of
democrats and yes republicans as well
the republicans as well don't get me
wrong of democrats immediately saying
give us cash so that we can fix this
when we know why this happened and part
of it has to do with democrats and of
course much of it has to do with the
fact that i mean when we you start the
sequence of events
it's donald trump won in 2016 and then
appointed supreme court justices and
then it was the exact playbook
republicans started challenging abortion
at the state level with the goal of
appealing it to the supreme court with
the goal of getting the supreme court to
overturn roe v wade we we predicted it
in 2016 and that's exactly what happened
let's check out this video um
absolutely fascinating and well said so
i received a text message from joe
biden's campaign yesterday saying that
the supreme court had overturned rope
versus wade and that it was my
responsibility to then rush 15 to the
democratic national party um and i
thought that was absolutely outrageous
because my rights should not be a fun
fundraising point for them um or a
campaigning point
they have had multiple opportunities to
codify row into law over the past 20 30
40 50 years and they haven't done it and
if they're going to keep campaigning on
this point they should actually do
something about it what are you most
worried about julian
i'm most worried about what comes next
because roe versus wade was a president
for oberval vs hodges loving versus
virginia irving versus texas gay
marriage interracial marriage and
privacy in the bedroom correct and those
as clarence thomas came out yesterday
they're going to be falling like
dominoes
you come from texas you're in austin
texas there's a trailer law in place in
austin in 30 days abortion's going to be
banned in your state abortion has been
banned at six weeks in my state since
last september which is an essential
all-out ban because most women don't
even realize they're pregnant before
that point and there when there are
women in texas who've already died and
have already been arrested for having an
abortion or a miscarriage because we
can't really tell that it seems like you
have obvious anger towards the
democratic party because you feel as if
they've missed chances to codify a row
up until this point and then here we are
what does that mean for you when it
comes to midterm elections and getting
more democrats um elected to move
forward with trying to codify um roe
well when it comes down to the the
primaries which i think are coming up in
the next couple months
it means that we need to get as many
people to the polls as possible to vote
for more progressive democrats we need
to get the old white democrats out of
office and put in new younger people who
will actually defend the rights of women
and people all over this country and
then when it comes to midterms we need
to make sure that we have those same
people who voted for the progressive
people in the primaries coming back to
the midterms and voting again and making
sure that these more progressive
democrats get into office and connect so
she's absolutely right i don't tend to
do the identity politics stuff in terms
of saying we need to get white democrats
out i want a diversity of representation
that that that's me okay so don't
ascribe saying get white people out to
me that's not the way i would i would
use that term but
this is completely spot on in the sense
that both parties have used abortion
rights
as a divisive fundraising issue for
decades i happen to agree
with the political position of the
democrats as an individual because i'm
pro-choice but this has been an issue
that's been a fundraising issue on both
sides for decades
in some sense
i recognized and i knew
that democrats i'm sorry that
republicans benefit from roe v wade in
the sense that it's something they can
keep fundraising on as long as roe v
wade is there
republicans can say give us money to
oppose roe v wade
now they've gotten roe v wade overturned
so some have been emailing and saying
well now now how are republicans going
to raise money well they're going to be
fine now they're going to say let's push
for a federal ban on abortion that would
be the next step now they've eliminated
roe v wade which kind of uh enshrines
abortion as as a right but the next step
would be well let's let's get a ban on
it and at the state level they can work
on bans they can start working on blue
states right even if it's unlikely to
succeed they can say give us money so we
can get abortion banned in california
and in connecticut and in new york and
massachusetts and maryland or whatever
else so they're still going to have ways
to fundraise and the crazy thing is
the republican continued fundraising on
this issue is is going to be more
credible feeling in a sense
because when you look at the democratic
party
the protesters here are correct
there have been so many missed
opportunities to codify roe v wade and
abortion rights and to do so many other
things so
while
you can pick the side that matches your
political position and say well i'll
give the money
the republicans now have actually
accomplished something major they they
have gotten roe v wade overturned and so
their fundraising on this issue is
almost more credible than that which
we're seeing by democrats and i got
those fundraising emails as well it
there was something pathetic about it
there was something disgusting about it
saying if they overturned roe v wade
send us 15 now 15 to do what exactly
particularly when uh we we need people
in the democratic party in elected power
uh who are going to fight much harder
for it so very interesting very
interesting viral viral
interview there and uh we'll continue
covering that
one of our sponsors is emmy
hands down some of the best ramen
noodles i've had just like any instant
ramen you pop emmy into the microwave or
on the stove top for a few minutes and
it's ready to go but what makes imme
different is that it is packed with 21
grams of protein
lower in sodium 100 plant-based with 18
grams of fiber for digestive health and
it tastes
excellent
so many of the other ramens are bland
simple artificial imi uses high quality
ingredients and recipes you get a zing
of flavor i've never had with any
instant ramen emmy comes in amazing
flavors like spicy beef tom yum shrimp
and black garlic chicken if you try emmy
and don't love it
you get your money back you'll get five
dollars off when you go to emmyeats.com
pacman and use the code pacman at
checkout the link is down below